olá a todos bom dia
é eu queria fazer um exercício com vocês
inicial queria pedir para vocês fecharem
os olhos um minutinho e pensarem num
prato que leve vocês diretamente para a
infância de vocês pensaram já estão com
fome que vai chegar ao intervalo a gente
então marcel proust foi um dos primeiros
autores a usar o olfato eo paladar como
gatilho de memória que quer dizer isso
um dia ele estava olhando um bolinho
chamada lei no chá e ele lembrou e
resolveu escrever o livro em busca do
tempo perdido porque o sabor daquela
comida levou ele diretamente para as
memórias da infância dele
poucas coisas na nossa vida aguçam tanto
os nossos bons sentimentos como a comida
isso se chama memória gustativa por isso
que eu perguntei pra vocês do tráfico
não é gente que vocês lembrarem eu
queria perguntar mais uma coisa é você
se lembrarão da mãe de vocês da avó de
vocês de uma viagem de um lugar em
especial né porque a comida ela tem essa
propriedade ela tem e se essa força e
esse poder de transportar gente né
agora aí que vem a dúvida se a gente
perguntar sobre os jovens hoje para as
crianças
será que eles vão lembrar de um prato da
mãe de um prato da avó de um prato de
uma tia porque as pesquisas recentes
elas mostram que as novas gerações
elas não têm essa memória que a gente
tem elas lembram de marcas de comida
então quando você pergunta para eles a
equipe que você lembre que você mais
gosta quando você era pequeno tal uma
coisa que seja ele vai falar uma marca
pra você
então essas marcas gente industriais
elas são produzidas por cientistas né
essas coisinhas dessas indústrias
grandes de comida que a gente encontra
facilmente hoje em dia que a gente
compra de um pacote coloca no micro
ondas
resolver nossa vida porque a indústria
falou pra gente você não precisa mais
cozinhar você não precisa mais ir pra
cozinha já resolveu o seu problema
só que essa comida não é pilotada gente
nem por mim nem pela sua avó nem pela
sua mãe ela é pilotada por cientistas né
que cientistas fazem eles fazem tudo
parecer a comida da nossa avó
eles colocam ingredientes é químicos é
que vão fazer com que a gente queira
comer mais né que a gente fica um pouco
viciado nessa comida
será que a nossa avó confiava esses
ingredientes
acho que não né gente então eu acho que
é o momento da gente parar será que a
gente confia em tudo que estão dando pra
gente quando a gente vai no supermercado
ea gente compra um pacote de pão ea
gente vai ler o rótulo do pão você tem
que fazer isso gente tem tudo ali tudo
menos pão né a última coisa que você vai
ver é farinha de trigo água e fermento
você vai perguntar mato não sei o que lá
coisa que a gente nem sabe que que é
coisa que a gente não encontra numa
cozinha nem da casa da gente então aqui
que eu quero chegar com vocês
será que a gente está usando bem o nosso
tempo gente porque o nosso problema não
é com comida não tem tempo não tem tempo
pra cozinhar gente não tenho tempo pra
fazer nada então é muito mais fácil
comprar uma pizza comprar um negócio já
coloco lá já está pronto né
será que a gente está tão ocupado assim
quando a gente está na nossa casa é que
a gente pode desligar um pouquinho a
televisão o celular
o tablet né e prestar atenção no que a
gente está colocando da boca pra dentro
porque se a gente continuar assim não
prestando atenção e não presente no
momento da gente se alimentar
a gente vai só está dando na verdade a
atenção da boca pra fora
quero chamar a atenção de vocês para a
presença no ato da gente se alimentar né
foi tão bonita palestras todos os meus
dois antecessores aqui porque a gente no
fundo está falando da mesma coisa cada
um numa coisa diferente mas da mesma
coisa a gente tem que estar presente
gente a gente tem que pensar no que a
gente vai comer preparar a nossa comida
arrumar nossa mesa colocar até uma
música pra gente tem um momento
agradável momento de paz um momento
nosso pra nós é um presente pra mim isso
não é uma obrigação né
especialmente mastigar
porque gente vai chegar muito engraçado
eu vou num ispaia frequenta o spac no
brasil maravilhoso e o segundo terceiro
dia que você tá lá você tem uma aula de
mastigação primeira vez que eu fui falei
nossa gente vai acontecer mas chegar não
é possível né
daí que ele fala pra gente ficar mais
quieto quando a gente está comendo a
gente fechar a boca porque a gente
engole áreas de ficar com gases
fala pra gente vai chegar lá ele só pra
gente vai chegar a 40 vezes acha que vai
morrer é porque é surreal se bota uma
gordurinha na boca 40 vez virá um
líquido mas pelo menos 20 na gente
porque a gente já começa a digerir essa
comida na nossa boca ea gente só vai ter
benefício a gente vai ter na realidade
nosso cérebro ele precisa de 20 minutos
para ele entender que ele está mais
associado
gente estou falando para vocês mas eu
faço bastante coisa errada também tá
então eu volto para as coisas que eu
aprendi para as coisas que eu tenho que
fazer para melhorar
então quando a gente mastiga a gente vai
mandando aquela informação olha você já
está satisfeito então o que vai
acontecer com a gente a gente vai querer
comer - a gente vai se saciar mais
às vezes a gente terminou de comer num
uma coisa tão rápido a gente está com
fome né é tão doido isso e aí a gente
vai de gerir melhor o nosso
funcionamento de ensino vai ser melhor
simplesmente com a mastigação olha só eu
nem falei de comida ainda né
nem falei de preparo nem nada disso é e
o que a gente mais ouve falar hoje eu
vocês a gente ouve falar de obesidade
neodi os problemas prementes no brasil
nunca gente já ouviu falar tanto em
refluxo na nossa vida porque eu tenho 55
anos a gente não falava de refluxo no
máximo falava de azia né
só que na real é porque a gente come
bebe come bebe e vai no bexiga tal
aquilo volta gente ea gente come mais do
que a gente está precisando também na
verdade o que a nossa atenção está
completamente outro lugar
quando a gente fala de qualidade de vida
é é tão legal nem outro dia fui uma
palestra e uma moça perguntou do outubro
rosa é o que a gente achava um grupo de
mulheres
e aí uma maquiadora falou olha a
primeira coisa que o põe pra dentro da
minha boca então pra gente ter qualidade
de vida para a gente ter saúde primeira
coisa que eu ponho pra dentro da minha
boca que a gente não pensa gente mas a
alimentação a coisa mais importante na
nossa vida é o número 1
aí o que a gente tem que estar
preocupado hoje com a qualidade não a
quantidade né ea gente é aquilo que eu
falei eu erro às vezes eu chego na minha
casa eu quero abrir um salgadinho que
estou com preguiça mas a gente sempre
tem que entender que o ano tem 365 dias
cada dia um presente cada dia momento de
recomeçar
quando a gente acha que está descambando
um pouco a gente fala opa
o pará que voltar de novo pensar nisso
novamente quantas vezes a gente precisar
a gente nós estamos aqui pra isso nós
estamos aqui na terra para aprender todo
dia pra recomeçar todos os dias
ninguém perfeito ninguém faz tudo sempre
igual você não seria muito chato
e aí eu acho assim também pode ser um
programa tão legal sabe todo mundo se
reunir no final de semana a família
vocês elegerem aí um dia fazem uma
compra juntos discutem um pouco que vão
fazer na semana que vão preparar os
filhos participam sabes é mudar as
dinâmicas eu sei que estou falando isso
vou falar silva recebeu só acho que meu
filho vai querer falar disso vai gente
vai achar engraçado se você inclusive é
uma tarefa para participar falou filhos
recebem sair o que você vai querer
começa a semana vamos discutir isso
tornar isso uma coisa colaborativa de
todos não é que todos participem porque
pesa só a mãe tem que pensar
sua mãe tem que falar
sua mãe vai comprar e aí todo mundo
falar assim pois não gosto disso
você sabe que eu não quero isso mas o
cara participou o que ela pediu então é
gostoso fazer isso todo mundo junto né
e hoje a gente no mercado de alimentação
a gente tem muita oferta gente quando eu
comecei no restaurante já nada hoje você
tem tudo então vejo você comprar um pão
de pacotes e pode comprar um pão bacana
de fermentação natural porém falando em
fazer e você fatia ele coloca em fatias
no freezer e vai tirando a medida das
suas necessidades e já fez um trabalho
para a semana é uma questão de
planejamento gente é e aí também eu vou
ser um pouco chato agora mas eu acho que
a gente tem que priorizar os orgânicos
também a gente fala bastante nesse
assunto mas é porque assim é o nosso
organismo ele tem uma tolerância para
fertilizantes pra adoçantes pra
hormônios ea gente sem perceber uma vez
eu li essa taxa do adoçante falar
imagina mas eu só tomo dois cafés por
dia só estava em 2 a 2 antes só que a
gente come pão light coisa light
refrigerante light a gente vai a gente
vai afundando nessa nessa cota né
quando chega no final do dia nós já
ultrapassamos isso então se a gente
puder diminuir o impacto dessas coisas
na nossa saúde o ideal eu quero sempre
falar sobre equilíbrio gente não dá pra
gente fazer uma uma refeição 100%
orgânica que todo mundo trabalha no seu
trabalho não tem no restaurante difícil
essa compra você não tem esse e se essa
abastecimento né porque o orgânico é
assim uma hora ele tem uma hora ele não
tem não dá pra fazer um menu assim mas
na sua casa escolha melhor sabe
diminua o impacto disso cumpre frutas
legumes assim procure comprar os ovos
caipiras procure comprar os frangos sem
tanto os hormônios que você está
contribuindo para a sua saúde
é aí também naquela preparação foi todo
mundo comprar as coisas já pode adiantar
um serviço lavar as folhas já num dia só
se você tem uma pessoa que te ajuda na
sua casa uma funcionária que lavasse
jacek já deixou escapar o é porque
quando chegar no fim do dia cansado
você não precisa fazer uma pizza você
vai lá e você pega essas folhas fazer
uma salada já tem alguma coisa grelhadas
e pode fazer aquilo que eu falei uma
programação da sua comida netherlands
naturais como frutas legumes
os molhos preparados quando faz feijão
já faz pra semana - pacotes abertos e
mais mão na massa
por falar na mão na massa gente sabe em
quanto tempo leva para fazer um
carbonara por exemplo gente são 15
minutos sem brincadeira a primeira
decisão de uma errada mas depois vão que
sejam beleza quanto tempo leva um
delivery gente é 15 minutos que chega na
casa da gente no mínimo 40 anos está com
aquela sorte e quanto custa se delivery
gente porque um espaguete à carbonara
pra uma pessoa vai precisar de dois ovos
100 gramas de espaguete umas 30 gramas
de bacon cabo o seu prato e umas 30
gramas de parmesão
comer é a coisa mais natural e mais
ancestral desse mundo né gente a
primeira coisa que a gente faz a
primeira coisa que um bebê faz ea gente
acabou transformando alimentação num
show de mágica né
a gente vai querer ver as coisas
moleculares as coisas com fumaça com
aromas né e aí também a gente não pode
esquecer de fotografar porque senão a
gente não tá se não tá no restaurante a
gente não foi
a gente não comeu e onde é que tá nossa
presença gente onde nós tamo né
a gente tá aonde no celular
o celular gente nem deveria estar à mesa
a comida é presença é afeto é alimento é
cultura e é agregador
né essa conversa mim era rápida na hora
da receita pra vocês
depois vão atrás de mim não viria no meu
site resolver tudo isso quem quiser
falar comigo estou à disposição mas é
pra gente é um convite pra vocês
cozinharem com simplicidade gente com
genuinidade de verdade para proporcionar
essa memória do filho de vocês né
quero muito que vocês vão para casa
pensando no prato vocês vão preparar
para o neto de vocês lembrarem de vocês
é isso